[Music]
[Applause]
how can this coding still be on here
okay some backstory on why i did this to
a brand new iphone 8.
you may have heard of this thing called
the coronavirus piranovirus the
coronavirus outbreak
and that everyone wants to clean off
everything with
well just about anything to protect
themselves
you may have also heard that you should
never ever
ever use liquid cleaning supplies on
your smartphone that's because your
smartphone screen
has a protective coating to repel both
water and oil
you may have heard it marketed as the
oleophobic coating
basically it minimizes fingerprints and
smudges
you can see the difference here the left
side of this phone has the oleophobic
coating
the right side does it then i placed a
drop of
olive oil on each side you can see that
on the coating side
the oil droplet quickly repels on the
side with no coating it sticks and has a
harder time coming off the screen
the chemicals and abrasive materials in
some cleaning products can destroy that
coating
in fact after many years of saying just
use a microfiber cloth
apple okayed the use of disinfecting
wipes like clorox and lysol
and wipes with 70 isopropyl alcohol
but how many wipes does it take to take
off this coating
and what does it look like when the
coating's all gone i scrubbed a lot
for science
now we're talking
[Music]
i wanted to preserve the oleophobic
coating on one side of the screen
so i covered that side with paper and
tape
then i began scrubbing the other side
with these clorox disinfecting wipes
i did 365 wipes i figured
one scrub a day or a year this feels
very wasteful
and one
two
three hundred and sixty five
i did not let it dry for the recommended
four minutes
because well i have a life i really
should have worn
gloves i'm super wrinkled like i just
took a bath
and caloric swipes the results the
coating was
totally fine so i decided to keep wiping
for another
two years even after 1095 wipes the
coating appeared
intact the screen still felt smooth and
repelled the oil and water
so i upped the challenge using some
explicitly banned cleaning supplies
it was on right i was told that
hydrochloric acid
found in toilet bowl cleaner would
destroy the coating
after 10 minutes of scrubbing with it it
seemed totally fine
a magic eraser which has abrasives still
pretty fine i'm doing a lot of squeaking
though i only did it for about two
minutes
car buffer nah but it was fun
[Music]
finally i decided to go all out after
two hours in a tub of toilet bowl sauce
the coating was finally starting to come
off
i topped it off with some soft scrub
with bleach and nail polish remover
we've heard
acetone is bad for screen there's
acetone in nail polish remover
help me finally as you can see
the oil on the right side of the screen
where the coating had been stripped
began to repel much slower than on the
left
but you don't have to go to all these
lengths to take off the coating
it turns out that after normal use the
oleophobic coating on any phone will
just start to wear
by the way the phone worked and turned
on perfectly fine at the end of all of
this
so after all of this what do you do
if you're just looking to clean your
phone cosmetically get a microfiber
cloth
but if you want to disinfect and kill
all the germs use a disinfecting wipe
heck use 365 of them
if you're still worried and you don't
like getting your hands wet you could
try a uv
phone sanitizer like this 100 phone soap
go
that promises to kill 99 of bacteria and
germs
i did not test that claim myself
i now resign as the leading phone
cleaning columnist at the wall street
journal
i'm never testing phone cleaning again
[Music]
ever